,
THEY ARE HELL-BENT ON
DISMANTLING THE LAW AND ORDER.
YOU CAN TELL BY THEIR ACTIONS,
HERE WITH MORE CENTER TED CRUZ,
SENATOR, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T RECALL YOU DENYING RIOTS
FOR RIOTS LAST YEAR.
I DON'T KNOW ANY REPUBLICAN THAT
WASN'T OUT THERE SAYING WE NEED
TO RESTORE LAW AND ORDER AND I
DON'T KNOW ANY CONSERVATIVES
SAYING WE NEED TO DEFUND AND
DISMANTLE THE POLICE.
IF YOU REMEMBER, PLEASE TELL US
BECAUSE MY MEMORY IS PRETTY
SHARP ON THESE ISSUES.
>> WELL, SEAN COME I HAVE TO SAY
IT IS REMARKABLE THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS APPARENTLY EMPLOYING
COMEDIANS.
THERE IS AN OLD MUNITION WORD
FOR THAT GOOD SPOT.
FOR THEM TO RUN OUT AND CLAIM
REPUBLICANS WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE IS LIKE AN ARSONIST
SHOWING UP AT THE FIRE AND
BLAMING THE FIREMEN.
THAT IS LIKE THE CHINESE BLAMING
THE AMERICANS FOR THE WUHAN
VIRUS.
THAT IS LIKE O.J. SAYING HE'S
GOING TO HELP FIND THE REAL
KILLER.
THAT IS LIKE DEMOCRATS SAYING
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT WANT TO
BUILD THE WALL.
IT IS ABSURD.
IT IS RIDICULOUS AND THEY KNOW
IT, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY WERE
COUNTING ON THE MEDIA ALL
ENCIRCLING JOE BIDEN AND SAGGING
"POOR UNCLE JOE, HE DOESN'T WANT
TO DEFUND THE POLICE."
THE LAST TIME BILL de BLASIO
THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF NEW YORK
CAN CUT A BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE NYPD.
AND de BLASIO ON THAT SAME
DEMOCRATIC STAGE WITH JOE BIDEN.
YOU MIGHT NOT REMEMBER IT BUT
de BLASIO WAS THERE APPEAR AT
LAST I CHECKED, HE WAS A
DEMOCRAT LAST I CHECKED OMAR IS
A DEMOCRAT, LAST I CHECKED THE
SUMMER OF LOVE, REMEMBER YOU HAD
A DEMOCRAT GOING COME AT US JUST
THE SUMMER OF LOVE.
I WANT TO SEE THE DEMOCRATS MAKE
THE CASE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PUT US IN CHARGE LIKE THE MAYOR
OF PORTLAND CAN SAY, PUT US IN
CHARGE AND A POLISH OR POLICE.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE MURDER
RATE, WE CAN INCREASE IT EIGHT
TIMES, 800%, LOOK THE DEMOCRATS
UNDERSTAND THEY ARE IN TROUBLE.
ABOLISHING THE POLICE IS STUPID.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
BY THE WAY, AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AND HISPANICS OVERWHELMINGLY
OPPOSE ABOLISHING THE POLICE.
SUDDENLY, THE RICH, WHITE
LIBERALS WHO SAID LET THEM BE
WITHOUT THE POLICE ARE
REALIZING, OH, NO, THIS IS
UNPOPULAR AND SO THEY ARE TRYING
TO CLAIM THESE ARE NOT WHAT YOU
ARE LOOKING FOR AN EVER
SUPPORTED IT.
IT IS ABSURD TO COME IT IS
RIDICULOUS.
SEAN, YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
JOE BIDEN THINKS, LOOK NO
FURTHER THAN TO THE SENIOR
OFFICIALS HE APPOINTED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY ARE TWO OF THE LEADING
ADVOCATES FOR DEFINING AND
ABOLISHING THE POLICE.
LAST YEAR IN WRITING A
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY THEY
ADVOCATED IT.
BIDEN APPOINTED TO THE TWO TOP
POSITIONS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE VOTE FOR THE
CONFIRM OF BOTH OF HIM, ALL 50.
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT VOTED TO
CONFIRM VOCAL ADVOCATES FOR
ABOLISHING THE POLICE.
THAT IS WHO IS HELPING RUNNING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RIGHT
NOW.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY THAT
SUCCESSFULLY A GREAT TRACK
RECORD ACTUALLY ARGUED BEFORE
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
AND EVEN ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAID
YOU ARE ONE OF THE BRIGHTEST
STUDENTS THAT HE EVER HAD, THE
HONOR OF HAVING IN HIS CLASS.
YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
CONSTITUTION, AND YOU STEP IN
AND CORRECT ME ANY POINT I AM
WRONG, I UNDERSTAND IT TO BE THE
FOUNDATION FOR OUR RULE OF LAW
IN THIS GREAT DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC THAT WE LIVE IN.
WHEN WE HAVE LAWS COME I ALWAYS
THOUGHT, YOU KNOW, WE GET TO
PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH ONES TO
DECIDE TO OBEY.
YOUR STATE OF TEXAS AND ALL OF
THE BORDER STATES ARE NOW LIVING
WITH RECORD LAWLESSNESS.
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY JUST BEING
PROCESSED AND ALLOWED TO ENTER,
BUT THEN, IT SEEMS JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS' POLICIES AIDING
AND ABETTING LAWBREAKING AS THEY
THEN DISPERSE AND GIVE TRAVEL
ASSISTANCE TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TO OTHER STATES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
IS THERE ANYTHING LEGAL ABOUT
THAT, SENATOR?
I WILL BE DOWN AT THE BORDER
WITH GREG ABBOTT WHO I'M FOND OF
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP TOMORROW.
>> >> AS YOU KNOW IT IS COMPLETE
LAWLESSNESS AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REFUSES TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, I
BROUGHT 19 SENATORS DOWN TO THE
BORDER TO SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
I'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER MANY,
MANY TIMES AND BORDER PATROL AND
NIGHT CONTROL COMMIT IS WORSE
THAN IT'S EVER BEEN.
OVER HALF A MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
CROSSED ILLEGALLY AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU FOR MANY PEOPLE
CROSSING ILLEGALLY, THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE APPREHENDED BY THE
BORDER PATROL.
THEY SEEK OUT THE BORDER PATROL
AND TURNED THEMSELVES IN BECAUSE
OF KAMALA HARRIS, AND JOE BIDEN,
KAMALA HARRIS ARE THE LAST MILE
OF THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING NETWORK
THAT IS RESULTING AND ABUSING
THOUSANDS OF LITTLE BOYS,
THOUSANDS OF LITTLE GIRLS.
IT IS UTTERLY LAWLESS AND
STRIKING SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING
TO THE BORDER, AND WE ARE GLAD
TO WELCOME HIM IN TEXAS.
IF KAMALA HARRIS FINALLY
DISCOVERED WE HAD A SOUTHERN
BORDER AND TRAVEL TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BUT AMAZINGLY
ENOUGH SHE DID NOT GO TO THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
SHE DID NOT GO TO THE EPICENTER
OF THE PROBLEM.
SHE MEANT TO EL PASO WHICH IS A
WONDERFUL CITY, BUT IT IS
800 MILES AWAY.
IT IS CHICAGO IS CLOSER TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., THAN EL PASO
TO THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
AND THERE WAS A REASON, SEAN,
KAMALA DIDN'T GO TO THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
BECAUSE IF SHE HAD, SHE WOULD
HAVE HAD TO HAVE SEEN THE BIDEN
CAGES.
YOU HAVE SEEN FOR BIDEN CAGES.
CAGE AFTER CAGE AFTER CAGE OF
LITTLE CHILDREN APPEARED AND SHE
DIDN'T WANT THE NEWS MEDIA TO
COVER IT BECAUSE THE MEDIA TODA,
THEY DON'T PRETEND ANYMORE.
THEY ARE THE PRAETORIAN GUARD
PROTECTING BIDEN AND HARRIS.
SHE WENT TO EL PASO TO SASE THEM
I WENT TO THE BORDER AND
EVERYTHING IS FINE HERE WHILE
IGNORING WE ARE ON PACE FOR
MORE THAN 2 MILLION PEOPLE TO
CROSS ILLEGALLY AS A CRISIS.
YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW BAD IT IS?
McALLEN, TEXAS, DOWN A GREAT
CITY IN THE RIO GRANDE,
HISTORICALLY BRIGHT BLUE, 80%
DEMOCRATIC THEY ELECTED A
REPUBLICAN MAYOR BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE SAID ENOUGH ALREADY WITH
THIS CHAOS THAT JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS HAS GIVEN
US.
WE NEED TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND
SECURE THE BORDERS.
>> Sean: SENATOR, THAT WOULD
BE A GOOD START.
I NEVER KNEW YOU COULD PICK AND
CHOOSE THE LAWS AND I NEVER
THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT COULD PICK AND
CHOOSE EITHER.
I GET TO BE IN THE HOME STATE OF
TEXAS.
AND I THINK THIS WILL BE MY 15TH
TIME BEING DOWN THERE RIO GRANDE
ALL THE WAY THROUGH SAN DIEGO AT
THE ACTUAL BORDER, BY THE WAY,
JUST IN CASE ANYONE IS
INTERESTED.